cuando tú le compras a tu país una parte
del valor del tesoro de ese país
esencialmente lo que estás obteniendo es
un préstamo de ese estado así que vamos
a verlo mejor con un ejemplo para que
quede mucho más claro supongamos que
este es un papel que dice que al dueño
de este papel se le van a pagar mil
pesos cuando transcurra un año así que
veamos si tú compras esto de la
tesorería o tal vez de otra parte no
importa aunque para hacerlo más rápido
vamos a suponer que el gobierno expide
estos bonos justo ahora y que tú compras
cada uno de los bonos en los supongamos
950 pesos y el gobierno te dará este
título de seguridad que tenemos aquí
ahora bien cuando transcurre un año si
tú sigues teniendo este valor qué pasa
pues está escrito en el bono y aquí
tengo en la versión simplificada en la
cual dice que el propietario de este
bono ha transcurrido el año recibirá mil
pesos así que en este punto el gobierno
o la tesorería tendrá que darte mil
pesos así que si vemos este flujo de
dinero está muy claro que tú estás
prestando este dinero pues en un inicio
dice 950 pesos
un año después tú vas a recibir a
obtener mil pesos así que si hablamos en
términos financieros asociamos al
préstamo de dinero una tasa de interés
mi pregunta es cuánto es el interés que
obtuviste veamos dudas 950 pesos y
recibes mil pesos y es en este momento
en donde hay que llamar a la calculadora
para que realice las operaciones vamos a
ver
tengo mil ya esto lo voy a dividir entre
950 y esto me va a dar 1.0 526 1.0 526
qué quiere decir esto aquí ya me está
dando la tasa de interés pues me está
diciendo que yo obtuve el 100 por ciento
más un 5.26 por ciento adicional por lo
tanto para redondearlo yo voy a decir
que obtuve el 105 punto 3 por ciento
obtuvimos el 105 punto 3 por ciento del
dinero que prestamos al gobierno u otra
manera de ver dos la siguiente nosotros
podemos decir que préstamos 950 pesos a
una tasa de interés de 5.3 por ciento
anual después de un año tú tienes tu
dinero de regreso a más un 5.3 por
ciento
de tu dinero por el préstamo ahora bien
como a todos les agradó esta idea ahora
va a haber mucha gente que quiere
comprar estos bonos y por lo tanto en
los buenos van a subir de precio y van a
subir no sé supongamos a 980 pesos y
entonces me pregunta ahora es cuál es el
rendimiento implícito que hay cuando
nosotros obtenemos mil pesos después de
un año pues vamos a calcular mil entre
980 le da 1.0 204 lo cual voy a
redondear lo en 1.02 obtuve un 2% de
interés por lo tanto 102 por ciento de
mi dinero este que yo preste o una tasa
de interés del 2% por lo tanto cuando tú
prestas 950 pesos al gobierno tú tienes
una tasa de interés del 5.3 por ciento y
cuando tú prestas al gobierno 980 pesos
tú obtienes una tasa de interés del 2%
de tu préstamo y te estoy contando esto
por la siguiente razón date cuenta que
cuando aumenta el precio de nuestro bono
que adquirimos en la tesorería entonces
tu tasa de interés o tu rendimiento se
va a ir hacia
pues fíjate que en los dos casos va a
obtener mil pesos y es justo aquí cuando
dicen que cuando aumentan los precios de
los bonos la tesorería lo que realmente
está pasando es que está bajando el
rendimiento que obtienes al comprar esos
bonos si hay una mayor demanda en los
bandos de la tesorería entonces el
rendimiento va a caer y lo que vamos a
ver en el siguiente vídeo es cómo cambia
el valor de los bonos de la tesorería y
además su rendimiento cuando cambiamos
la fecha de vencimiento